可以让我们活到极致的
大家可以听一听
那么第一个呢
我觉得
你看
就是很多人总是在苦苦的
等待生命当中的所谓的贵人
以为成功一定要靠
一个拉自己一把的伯乐
却很少有人真正的意识到
其实在你的命运里边
最有力量的贵人
是你自己
就是贵人他能够给你一个机会
但能够抓住机会的
大家想想是谁啊？
朋友能够陪你走一段路
但是能陪你走完全程的
还是你自己啊
甚至你以为生活那些阻止你的
阻碍你的
打击你的人和事
其实我跟你们说到头来
你最大的敌人不是别人
而是内心那个胆怯
拖延
自我设限的自己
外界的这么一个
我觉得不过是放大了你内心的脆弱
所以
真正能够打败你的
就是你心里边那个
哎呀
这么一个声音
对吧
相反
我觉得真正能成就你的
是你告诉自己我能行
这次我不逃避了
我就要成为那个不一样的自己
所以你看
一个人真正的成长
就是从
转变开始的
第二
你看
很多人以为人生的胜利是击败对手
是赚到第一桶金
或者说自己站上了一个高位
可真正的强者知道
最难打赢的仗是什么？
一定是与自己
你是否能够战胜拖延症
哪怕每天只早起5分钟
你是否能够克服懒惰
逼自己在疲惫的时候依然完成目标
你是否能够打败内心的恐惧
在别人质疑你的时候
依然能够选择相信自己
你是否能够熬过情绪的洪水
理性的做出不后悔的决定
所谓
战胜自己
从来它不是一次热血澎湃的痛改前非
而是每天无数次的对
这么一个否定啊
那些看起来无所不能的人
我跟你说
不过是一次次的赢过了
昨天那个想躺平的自己而已
第三
很多人啊
习惯性的把希望寄托在别人的身上
等我爸妈拉我一把
等领导赏识我
等那个爱人回头来找我
可是人生最残酷的真相是什么？
你唯一能依靠的救星是你自己啊
没有人能够代替你吃下这份苦
咽下这口气
扛起这条命啊
你可以被别人暂时的拉一把
但你如果不改变
命运也只会反弹回来
所以
最幸运的人生从来不是不用吃苦
而是终于明白了
只有自己才是那盏灯啊
所以从此以后
不要再指望谁能救我
也不要再抱怨谁负了我
而是要开始问自己一句
我能为自己做些什么？
这是拯救自己的开始啊
我觉得也是你真正
成为
时刻
那么第四句话
成长最大的奖赏
不是世俗意义的成功
而是你回头看过去自己的时候
心里会轻轻的一笑
啊
原来我已经走了这么远了
那个曾经敏感脆弱
习惯讨好别人的我
已经慢慢学会了坚持自我
那个不敢表达
害怕被否定的我
现在也能够在众人面前自信的发言了
你会发现
人生最美的风景不在远方
而是在你自己身上
那些破茧成蝶的瞬间
那些痛苦挣扎的蜕变
那些熬过无数次黑夜的清晨
每一个你以为撑不下去的夜晚
都会在日后
成为你最动人的故事啊
所以我一直跟大家说
遇见更好的自己
它不是一句鸡汤
而是你此生
能够给自己
第五句话
很多人误以为爱自己是一种自私
是不在乎别人
可是当你真正爱自己的人
他才有能力去好好的爱别人呢
当你不再苛求自己完美
不再把别人的期待
当做自己的人生目标
当你开始心疼自己的辛苦
允许自己的脆弱
接受自己的不完美
你才会发现
那些你苦苦追寻的
这种
其实一直在你自己身上
你们想
一个不懂得爱自己的人
总是小心翼翼的在
别人的情绪里边漂泊
一个真正爱自己的人
他才能在风雨当中安住自己啊
在关系里边给别人
真正的这种爱与安全感
所以
爱的最高境界
我觉得不是找到一个爱你的人
而是成为一个
能好好爱自己的人
所以真正活到最高境界的人
他都会慢慢的明白
所有的贵人
敌人
胜利
幸运与美好
其实都是源于自己
一切因你而起
一切
也因你而来
当你真正的看清自己
战胜自己
拯救自己
成全自己
爱上自己的时候
你会发现
所谓人生的
不过是终于
活成了那个
连自己都羡慕的样子啊